clamecy c'est d'abord le règne d'un
homme bernard bach d'un maire socialiste
de 1977 à 2008
une figure locale élue mitterrandien
président du conseil général et député
un patron omniprésent dans la ville qui
a longtemps bénéficié des réseaux
politiques et de nombreuses subventions
mais les temps changent les services
publics s'en vont la maternité ferme et
clamecy bascule doucement dans ce qu'on
appelle la diagonale du vide et c'est
toujours comme ça lorsque le roi s'en va
les héritiers se déchirent autour de l'
empire et c'est exactement ce qui se
passe à clamecy avec une guerre civile
qui commence à 2008 on ne le sait pas
encore elle va durer jusqu'à aujourd'hui
un duel entre l'ancienne première
adjointe claudine boisorieux et un
candidat investi par les militants
socialistes duel extrêmement serré
claudine boisorieux l'emportent avec
seulement trois voix d'avancé au terme
d'une cadre angulaire
mais ça n'est pas fini on se retrouve
six ans après avec la maire sortante
claudine boisorieux à nouveau un
candidat investi par le ps local
et cette fois une seule petite voix
d'avancé au soir du scrutin
il arrive ce qui se passe souvent
l'élection est annulée on revote en 2015
et là tenez vous bien à la fin du
dépouillement
tout le monde retient son souffle les
deux camps sont à égalité alors on
recompte dans la nuit et on arriva à
nouveau une seule voix d'avancé
du jamais vu dans l'histoire politique
de notre région claudine boisorieux est
élue elle va accomplir son mandat
jusqu'à aujourd'hui elle ne se
représente pas en 2020 ce sont les
héritiers des héritiers qui seront en
lice
mais le passé n'est toujours pas soldé